what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down what appears to be a major
turning point in the seven deadly sins
story unless we get trolled again but to
be specific in this video I will discuss
what appears to be the end of the holy
war and the final defeat of a major
villain following a truly epic battle
that included important contributions
from all seven sins but if you think the
story might be over not so fast
stick around until the end of the video
where I will talk about what I think
will happen next and why I don't think
that the story is over just yet if you
enjoyed the seven deadly sins content on
this channel and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you
probably know that YouTube notifications
often don't work so the best way to get
notified for sure is to click the bell
and click off the option to receive all
notifications you can also follow me on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest news and updates
about the seven deadly sins including
news about the latest season of the
anime heads up this video will of course
include manga spoilers because we're
talking about the latest developments in
the seven deadly sins stories so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned chapter three three one starts
off with all seven sins charging at the
demon Kings latest form the Cthulhu
demon king the demon king hits back at
them with an attack which traps all the
sins
inside a large orb of darkness the demon
king tells the sins to get crushed out
of existence because insignificant
insects like them don't stand a chance
against a mountain and to be fair the
demon King's new form is literally as
big as a mountain at this point so this
time at least he is not exaggerating but
the sins begin to resist the power of
the orb we see Merlin reciting spells in
her strange incomprehensible language we
see ultimate esken or fighting back we
see bond king and everyone else pushing
back against the power of the orb the
demon king says that he will put an end
to the holy war by using all of the
life-forms with
and as his vessel but the sins refused
to accept the feat Deann king everyone
is determined to fight back and stop the
demon king from destroying the life
forms of Britannia Merlin that manages
to break the hold of the dark orbit by
using a spell that is apparently called
limit breaker and all the sins are
suddenly freed the demon king shouts at
Merlin saying that Valhalla wins
daughter is a deceitful wench who
tricked him back then and now she's
trying to foil his plans yet again this
is a reference to the previous holy war
when a young Merlin tricked both the
demon king and the supreme deity she
lied to both of them saying that she
will join their side in the holy war if
they gave her secret magical knowledge
both of them agreed and gave Merlin the
secrets that she wanted but instead of
joining either side Merlin simply bailed
on both of them and kept all the
knowledge for herself the demon king of
the supreme deity were furious and they
destroyed all of beli a lewin the
capital of the Wizards and Merlin's
hometown but Merlin survived back in the
present time all the sins rushed the
demon king and launched their own
special attacks in his direction the
demon king tries to use the ruler to
turn the attacks to his advantage but
Gothas ability called Killswitch is able
to negate the demon Kings magical
abilities nullifying the effects of the
ruler kudos to Gotha for finding a way
to be useful again even though in terms
of raw power he can't even compare to
the demon king and the rest of the main
cast the demon king then generates
another massive dark orb and tries to
use it as a barrier but all the attacks
of the sins which combined into a single
powerful fireball break through the orb
and continue their path in the direction
of the demon king in a last-ditch
desperate effort the demon king tries to
appeal to the sympathy of his sons Mele
Otis and zelgius he calls out and asked
them whether they are really going to
kill their own father in meliora
suddenly bafflingly steps up in front of
the fireball and uses full counter in
order to hit it away from the demon king
but instead of being grateful the demon
king immediately uses this opportunity
to attack meliodas from behind
even though meliodas just saved his life
however Mellie Otis is not that naive
and the demon king realizes when he
attacks malli Otis that this was not the
real Mellie Otis but rather a mirage
since Mellie Otis is using lost Wayne
it's safe to assume that this was just
one of the clones that he can generate
using that sword and now it makes sense
why Elizabeth made a point of returning
lost Wayne to meliodas before the
beginning of this fight
Mellie Otis says to the demon king that
he tried to give him one last chance he
tried to show mercy and then see what
the demon king would do with that mercy
but the demon king just attacked Mellie
Otis from behind
immediately after meliora saved his life
and now there is no doubt whatsoever
that the demon king is ruthless and evil
beyond salvation and this means that the
demon king does not deserve any mercy
meliodas then uses the rest of his
clones to keep full countering the
massive fireball over and over again and
every time he does this the power of the
fireball is doubled the demon king tells
me Leodis to stop because he won't
survive getting hit by that attack but
Mellie Otis has no more doubt about what
must be done he says goodbye to his
father and the demon king is destroyed
by this massive seven deadly sins combo
move on the final page an aged and
defeated demon king says to Mellie Otis
that he will regret this because the
cycle of light and darkness is never
ending and he is sure that Mellie Otis
is aware of that
Mellie Otis responds by saying that of
course he knows and the text on the
final page proclaims that the order of
darkness has fallen and the holy war has
concluded first of all I have to say
that I am NOT surprised by how the demon
king was defeated in a previous video
and honestly I forget which one exactly
I said that I think he will ultimately
be defeated with all seven sins working
together and creating an epic combo move
like the one in the prisoners of the sky
movie I just thought that this would be
a more satisfying conclusion to the
fight than just having one person say
meliora saw reskin or finishing off the
demon king on his own after all of this
is the seven deadly sins and even though
we know that at this point some sins are
much much stronger than others sorry
Diane it makes sense for NACA bouzouki
to ensure that every sin plays an
important role in ultimately defeating a
major boss like the demon
King so that's it right everybody I mean
it said that the holy war is over so it
must mean that it's really over they all
lived happily ever after
epilogue time seriously though the final
page and the words of the demon king
says to me Leodis represent an important
clue in my opinion the demon king said
that the cycle of light and darkness is
never-ending
Emily Otis has confirmed that he knows
this then the chapter tells us that the
holy war is over because the darkness
has been defeated but this is a cycle of
light and darkness so what about the
light sure we can say that the holy war
itself is over because that was a
conflict driven by two sides and the
driving force behind one of the sides
the demon king has apparently been
defeated but there is of course another
major figure that has been driving this
conflict another divine an extremely
powerful creature and that is
Elizabeth's mother the supreme deity the
holy war as we know it might be over but
this story is not over it is very
possible that now that the demon king
has been defeated the supreme deity will
feel emboldened to make her move and
finally emerge from the celestial realm
also now that the demon king is gone man
leotis is going to be considered his
successor and eliminating the successor
of the demon king could easily be the
first thing on the supreme deities mind
right about now I don't think it was a
coincidence or meaningless than in the
previous chapter we saw hawk and the
mother of chaos approaching the
battlefield I don't think that all the
foreshadowing about King Arthur was a
coincidence the demon king might be
defeated but the story is still not over
because from a narrative perspective
there is still so much that needs to be
resolved there are various translations
out there but according to some
translations the next chapter chapter 3
3 2 will be called requital the
definition of requital is something
given in return compensation or
retaliation also one of the definitions
of requited is avenging this does not
sound like the title of a chapter that
is going to feature everyone just going
back to their lives and living happily
ever after instead to me
it sounds like some new complications
may arise realistically the only big
unresolved question still remaining in
the series is of course the supreme
deity she is a crucial part of the story
the mother of Elizabeth and a key
component of that never-ending cycle of
light and darkness that the demon king
mentioned I've said this many times
before but I think that the only
satisfying ending for the seven deadly
sins will be formally Otis and Elizabeth
to replace their parents as the new
leaders of the demon and the goddess
clans if they are leading their clans
clans which have been at war for
thousands of years and yet the two of
them are together and love each other
they will serve as undeniable proof that
peace and coexistence between the two
clans is possible the only way that the
cycle of light and darkness will stop
leading to constant war and destruction
is if the people who lead the light and
the darkness are Elizabeth and meliodas
two individuals who reject war and
hatred because they love each other
despite the fact that they come from
rival clans after defeating demon king
malleolus could easily succeed his
father as the new demon king but for
Elizabeth to become the leader of the
goddesses she must first face off
against her mother the supreme deity now
maybe I'm wrong and malleolus will not
become the next demon king we all know
that he never wanted to be the demon
king and maybe zelgius will replace
their father instead after all zelgius
did want to become the demon king so
that he could rule in a more just and
fair way than his father
but whoever ends up becoming the next
demon king the fact remains that the
supreme deity is still a massive
unresolved plot point and I really don't
see how the story could be completed
without an appearance from the ruler of
the goddesses but let me know what you
guys think is the holy war really over
and has the demon king been defeated for
good this is like the third or fourth
time that he has been quote-unquote
defeated so far since he keeps just
changing his vessels at this point I
wouldn't be surprised if he starts using
knockabout Suzuki's body to right
malleolus and zelgius out of the story
altogether
but beyond the demon king what do you
think the future will bring are we
finally going to see the supreme deity
make her move personally I think we have
to see something happen with her before
the story ends
just wouldn't make much sense otherwise
but that is my opinion feel free to
share your opinion down in the comments
below
whenever we have such watershed moments
in the manga I always love to get a good
conversation going down in the comments
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more seventh at least sense
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you have it to be new
to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar for all the latest seven
deadly sins news and updates I want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
out pro patrons who make videos like
this one possible special thank you to
all of our pro hero to your patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King's
eldest on hell cruise stealers poet
Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat a karate
Gian Anatole Cassatt's ki DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including Ingrid ah alone
Adam Maddie Mac makoto-kun and ya boys
Seth if you enjoy our videos and you
think that they add some value to your
life consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]